I am so paulo here an assistant
professor of national security affairs
at the US Naval Postgraduate School in
Monterey California and a young global
leader so today the recession that
caught my attention the most was run on
responsible government because I do work
on responsible government in my research
which I call good governance essentially
George Soros has said that misery and
poverty are are are the main impediments
really more for the world's poor and
global populations in and that
government is one of the main drivers of
that so responsible government which i
think is a politically correct way of
calling good government is is really
important we see this throughout Latin
America now I last couple of days then
the nationalization of the largest oil
producer in Argentina is causing a lot
of friction with other Latin American
countries which which of course don't
want to be associated with expropriation
of private companies resources or assets
and so the real the real challenge here
is how do you run how do you run a
government that is other people invited
people and I think that that it's
something that is happening in some
countries in Latin America and better
you see certainly the flop Venezuela you
see the progress happening now in
Argentina but you also have after seven
years of one party worker you've seen in
the last through elections really a
transformation in Mexico and maybe
another change of government that this
next election so it's going to be a
great opportunity to see how democracy a
box here in Mexico next step
so that session was an eye-opener and I
think generally this whole forum has
been wonderful opportunity to exchange
ideas thanks